[Music]
hello and welcome to this video
yeah this is the video for our chapter 2
of the opening course about how to fight
me for like Fabiano Khurana yeah this
video 2 chapter 2 is about sidelines on
move to so we're talking about p45 and
how white goes for a sideline that is
north d4f for that is chapter 1 yeah so
we're not dealing with the early gambits
let's say Oh on the early attacking
moves even though some of the lines are
somewhat similar spirit let's say as the
Kings gambit or so but I had to simply
split all the odds and ends into two
chapters otherwise it would just be to
the enormous for one so in this chapter
we have all the all the other lines of
which most important are Knight c3 the
Vienna game quite transpositional but
still Vienna and most importantly we are
dealing with Bishop c4 the bishops
opening as it is called this is by far
the most important move on the
professional at the professional level
because this is the only way really that
promises some sort of an I don't think
White has an advantage but white can try
to play for something while avoiding the
petrov altogether so this is a move that
is has been played quite extensively
against Khurana to avoid his petrov
preparation in this chapter we will look
at those two moves but also yeah look at
some real rarities those are not very
dangerous but it's useful to know them
and know the odds trap and odd weird
idea to avoid any sort of trouble so
let's look at the obscure lines first
and then go to the Vienna and the
bishops opening
the first move I want to check is the
move Queen to h5 yeah white is going for
us colors made yeah on the f7 square
yeah this move is somewhat infamous said
it's played by nakamura quite a bit
actually in the mid early 2000s it is
not great the Queen loses time but it
also is not so terrible that white will
be immediately clearly worse so okay we
cover our opponent five and white goes
Bishop c4 threatening checkmate
yeah don't fall asleep now we have to
cover the mid and I recommend to play g6
it's very logical and Queen a three-wide
insists on threatening mate and now
simply Knight f6 is good to develop this
piece and here the only thing that we
need to remember and it's fairly obvious
is that we go for fianchetto we're
basically trying to yeah make g6 count
as a constructive move so the bishop is
good on g7 it always covers c5 and after
D three to six I think black is quite
harmoniously placed it's not that black
has a clear advantage this is just yeah
even after a slightly silly opening not
not so easily possible but here we are
find the good ideas to play Bishop e6 or
Knight a5
Trading White's most active piece I
don't see any issue for black just don't
feel too provoked by Queen age five it
is a bit silly yeah but it's not so
terrible that you should look for quick
refutation quickly so I mean back to the
starting position here Queen h5 is quite
easily dealt with but again that's not
like you're winning immediately white
also has tried to move sunlight to eat
you that is very rare
I think it's called of course that the
allure pen I think it's named after a
lapel and yeah 92
it looks a bit passive and it is not
great however there are some some tricks
involved that we should avoid for
example we should not play 96 that
wouldn't quite fit with the Petrov
repertoires after d4 we don't have
anything better than take and we are in
a scotch opening and also I mean note
that this is not great for a petrol
player it's also not something that you
still want to allow after slightly or to
move like 92 my main recommendation is
to play the move Bishop c5 the bishop is
on a good diagonal and we have good
transposition of possibilities into a
line that we have examined in the first
chapter already and this is after deform
it looks quite logical takes Knight
takes Knight f6 and this is something
that we have looked at in the very first
chapter from a different move order that
started with two d4 to d5 84 903 Bishop
c5 and black is fine just then check
this if you want to learn a couple of
more moves but like us already in good
shape him instead of the most deform
white could try to get d-formed
supported here with the pawn against
this I recommend to play d5 that's a
typical way of handling such a situation
whenever white plays an early c3 and
makes Knight b2 c3 or interest III
impossible the quick d5 makes a lot of
sense after something like this the
Queen is just actively placed and we
have a very convenient position the same
thing applies against to c3 very very
rarely played but still I want to show
her that here again with d5
it's fine for black the Queen is simply
not in any way attackable on that square
with any any good move and as long as we
don't take on d4
for example after d4 sorry again after
d4 I would not take on the form but
rather develop and ask white how is
going how is how is continuing from this
from here we have an easy game develop
the bishop and can cancel long c3 is
extremely rare but I just wanted to show
that d5 is a good reply against very
early C threes because the Queen will
have an active position on d5 okay
another move that you can face and then
in fact something where there's a little
bit of trickery involved with signals a3
that looks very silly and wise white
playing such a move
just that you need to avoid one
particular thing and that is following
on out of six very logical to attack
them pawn on d4 93 and here is a
critical position a position that we
will also see a little bit later when
white starts with Knight c3 or move to
and what is it all about we should avoid
the very normal looking means d5 playing
in the scotch scotch style this is
actually not that great because after
the capture Knight takes White has the
interesting move Queen to h5 and this
compared to a Scotch opening is a case
where the move a3 makes a difference
because if that would be a Scotch with
the white pieces and black plays Queen
Jewish form the most critical line would
involve putting an idea which now is
impossible we have no problem at all
because we can alter the move over the
slide on here we should not play d5 we
want to play with five but we shouldn't
do it right away but rather start with
knight c6 and with this move
first we prevent this problems with the
pond hang on - now white does not really
have anything else and Knight f3 and
then be played on five this is a
position and a variation that we will
examine in a later video if I'm not
mistaken that should be chapter 3
actually the four Knights the rare for
Knights
so a three a bit odd but avoid the very
quick d5 you need to get the knight
words first and another one that funny
enough was played against me even though
in a super rare c4 I did in a classical
time control game once a couple of years
ago I was very surprised that you don't
really see that too often that why place
it before in c4 then overall
confirmation with those two pawns is in
fact quite common out of the English
opening where white starts with one c4
and in this move order it is called the
bot vinik setup or viniq variation this
you might still call like that because
technically it is before and c4 it's
about the next setup but this is a case
where black is in very very good shape
because we get an ideal formation
against it so I recommend 9 to 6 that's
a 3 and Bishop c5 this is the thing here
Lex formation is ideally coordinated to
control the weak D 4 square and now most
importantly the idea if you enjoyed the
free video preview make sure to go to
chesterlaw.com slash fight like a
Khurana to get to the full course the
full course with the move trainer and
video sync technology is an excellent
way to learn all the ideas and
strategies connected to this repertoire
these lines were essential in Kiwanis
fight to get the world title match and
they can be an essential part of your
opening repertoire as well
[Music]